okay guys here we are with another one
and this one we have dragon versus stoop
vlies and the time control was 15
minutes three second increment let's get
right into it another crazy one right
now this one is considered sort of a
miniature when it comes to computer
chess so let's see this one actually
this one's actually 31 moves miniature
right but here we go e4 c5 knight at
three knight and knight to f6 the nims
of its variations of the sicilian it's
aggressive and attacking it's weird it
throws people off so of course if you
want to looking for something actually
sicilian wise this one is actually a
very strange one to play as you see a
lot of strong players will actually play
this just to throw people off knight f6
hitting e4 and they're provoking you to
play e5 knight to c3 though from dragon
smarter than that but if you play knight
c3 we have the center break with d5
immediately boom nice move here breaking
in the center asking you what you're
gonna do b4 is coming e5 is coming a lot
of stuff is uh available bishop b5 check
for dragon which is a usual move
followed by bishop to d7 and after
bishop d7 we keep the pressure up this
game gets very wild actually capturing
this pawn will be very weak and it will
be able to be captured back almost
immediately and black has no issues so
to create issues dragon plays e5 which
is a nice move attacking the knight on
f6 black in response plays d4 keeping it
very strange very strange and making
sure your calculation is on point so
here guys would you take the knight or
would you move the knight your bishop is
connected so maybe you take here then
take the knife what do you actually do
in this position kind of strange what do
you do
here's the move in fact dragon says so
what make it complicated
make it complicated black's gonna be the
one out here looking crazy and how well
let's see e takes f6 d takes c3 f takes
g7 first so damaging the king structure
right ours is going to be pretty good
especially if we decide to castle f
takes g7 bishop or sorry c takes d2
first with check we respond to the check
the queen comes out instead of taking
with the bishop kind of wanted to defend
here and maybe actually get the queen
active via f4 g5 after bishop takes g7
instead of castling which loses a piece
immediately bishop takes d7 which helps
him develop a piece the move here was
actually a4 very hard move to find um
because you're voluntarily doubling the
pawns but you're saying hey you're not
going to castle at all and this position
is probably going to be slightly better
for white even though the structure is a
little bit weird we just have peace
activity a4 knight to c6 from stu please
saying uh you know we're not going to
have any of that you can uh you can have
it your bishop kind of looks strange
here especially with my knight on c6 but
we don't care dragon just castles gets
out the way knight d4 we want some
trades our position isn't the greatest
it looks like we want a castle but not
really i mean and then do we cast the
queen side
they played the sicilian right so a lot
of times it is harder to cast for
queenside in the sicilians certain ones
so after knight to d4 there was a trade
we take those he takes right back and
they clean to g5 definitely white is on
the attack here you would like to be
white in this position as we're just
active we're already castle the rook can
come to the file with a smile don't keep
your king in the center guys don't keep
your king
in the center i hope you're remembering
this taking notes don't keep the king in
the center watch this after queen g5
bishop f6 attacking the queen we gotta
move the queen so queen h6 we just get
out of the way have a nice day quite
simple queen h6 bishop takes b5 we trade
him off open the file with a smile we'll
take those right you're just going to
take back is that what you're going to
do chat you're going to take this right
right
or rookie one
when you find a good movie look for a
better one that's from lasker so ricky
won very nicely like how is this even
better bro what did he just
drop a piece when fact if you move the
bishop i take on f6
pressure why because your king is in the
center
your king is in the center
wow very nice so after rookie one rook
to g8 says go ahead you know what do you
think do your thing i'm gonna try to hit
you this way so queen takes f6 and
surprisingly did not go bishop c6
because of bishop g5
really really rough situation so bishop
to d7 from black bishop d7 backing up
and now do we put pressure right is
bishop g5 a move here
basic g5
it is a move but you have bishop e6 and
now i mean this is kind of strange and
sacrificing actually doesn't work on e6
like you would like to so it didn't work
didn't happen in fact after bishop b7 we
had to go back home but again the kings
in the center were about to take on h7
right so black plays h6 to stop kind of
all this
h7 business so he plays h6 i'm like yo
take it we're just trying to mess you up
really and white plays g3 which is a
very strong move letting us know hey the
engine is super strong but also saying
hey you know what we don't have to take
this right now and this is your pressure
point this is what you want to do so
we're going to stop you from doing it
and g3 now bishop c6 with queen d5
intentions but we say intentions because
you get mated if you move your queen off
the back ring too far think about moving
it too far you get made it so in fact
what uh what dragon did here was a cool
move queen f6
and at first i was like what in the
world does queen f6 actually do you're
probably asking that yourself what is
this move what does this actually do why
is my queen on f6 i mean yeah i'm
already pinning but why did i bring it
in closer well here's here's the answer
if e6 happens what do you do
what happens if e6 happens on the board
what do you think take a second here
it's a deterrent to e6 because of boom
right there rook takes e6
ouch hit that man with a move rook takes
e6 is nasty after takes you take with
the queen and if queen e7 and we take
those right and then we can move the
bishop out maybe some some more checks
don't hang mate i just don't do that you
know there's mate coming so you know you
can't
taking is you in a lot of trouble right
on the back right but you have queen g4
you should be end up winning this maybe
getting the bishop out quickly white's
just better in fact engine gives like
plus three there so after king f8 right
bishop takes h6 boom rook g7 and you
can't actually win this right now but
this is actually completely winning as
black is completely tied down this work
is out of the game so in fact you can
just look at it as like let's just move
this rick off the board it just
disappears because it's not even useful
the only pieces you're using are these
three and they're tied down right so
this is actually a very nice combination
that didn't happen after queen f6 there
was d3 realizing old snap my king in the
center rook's disconnected this is
already lost we're on move 18
d3 right so d3 happens white plays rook
to a3 who saw that one coming saying go
ahead take it d2 doesn't matter i'm
gonna take those you still gotta have
the queen definitely e7 nastiness so
after rook a3 he takes he says all right
cool i'm gonna take on c2 now what move
do you make guys rick a3 had an
intention to it always have intentions
to your moves why did you go here why
did you go here not only to put pressure
on d3 but to also
double on the file with a smile come on
now double wow this is gross now now
you're forced to play e6 and the rest is
history this is over rook takes c6 take
those take those right and then of
course in fact this one is strange let
me actually show you what happens on
bishop takes h6 this is actually a draw
now after rook g7 the reason i'm being
is because the pawns on c2 a lot of us
would actually go into this and it says
again if you're taking notes make sure
when you find a good move look for a
better one because this looked great
before but things changed and because
the position changed that means that
this same thing doesn't work any longer
you're actually down a full piece right
and uh he's about to queen there's a lot
of queen d1 action in there at the right
moment because if you get made it
quickly but it's uh it's scary it's
crazy how chess is sometimes instead of
bishop takes h6 there was this cool move
right here b3
unbelievable b3
out of all of that
stopping to play oh
b3 so after this b3 move it was pretty
nice right we about to go bishop a3
check that's the intention black plays
work to g5
and of course you know you could take
the rook
but that would be a fatal error while we
do that bishop a3 is what we wanted to
do this was our intention now after
bishop a3 there is an option to play
king g7 but after kg7 you run into this
line bishop here if king h7 then you
actually end up getting mated so after
king f8 you take on h6 i mean look at
this beautiful geometry here king g8
check right and because the rook is
stopping everything queen h7 right and
then after king f8 you go bishop a3 like
this is ridiculous like look at that a
little like geometry there hopefully you
did a good in geometry in school you
know because
it helps it helps all right so
queen f8 uh this actually didn't happen
king f8 right here b3
and then
rook uh rook g5 bishop a3 check and then
rick c5 boom rick c5 because he kind of
had to we saw the mate coming now if
this is your best move or the move
you're choosing you know it's already
over it was already over anyway though
but
now we just take the rook right
take c5 just take it right now as a
human
we're going to just take this rook
we're going to take this rook but
because this is an engine the best move
most accurate mate in seven is this move
right here like it's miraculous
sometimes like some of the moves they
make that's like what
but as a human you can just take the
rook queen f5 check right and then king
g7 and then we take the rook now right
let's take the one
take the rook
psych
bishop b2 check
vision b2 check we don't care about it
he's like bro take my rook
take my rook
take my rook right says stew fleas and
of course he's all right bro i gotta
take it this time bishop takes e5 check
very nice king g8 and then we're mating
check here
check there which bishop is important
you could attack with the queen as well
obviously but king to g8 bishop takes h6
king h8 and
queen g7 checkmate nice total blow there
one thing to take away from this game is
don't keep your king in the center the
trades was trying to happen trying to
get the trades off but was um uh was uh
unfortunately unsuccessful right didn't
work so make sure you don't keep your
king in the center because if you do
this could happen to you
in every one of your games right
hopefully you enjoy today's game if you
enjoyed this one check the next one
right above me don't go anywhere we're
gonna see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you